all right great story over at a Kyle
Cole in skis channel secular talk we did
the story about Trump surrogate Anthony
scaramouche II who got destroyed by
Chris Cuomo on CNN and he was touting
all sorts of debunked non science about
the climate he also referenced our
planet being fifty five hundred years
old it was bogus we covered that here's
another example of Chris Cuomo
absolutely destroying another Trump
surrogates Sean Spicer let's take a look
at what Kyle had to say and let's take a
look at what Sean Spicer had to say and
Chris Cuomo the entire thing CNN's Chris
Cuomo had on Trump surrogates Sean
Spicer whose name definitely sounds like
a porn star named Sean Spicer's as corny
as it gets and they went at it over
Trump's corruption and his electoral win
let's watch I get what the press wants
but the American people have understood
exactly what they're getting and they
voted overwhelmingly for him he has been
very clear about what he owns the role
of his family and everything else since
he announced that he was running for
president and they overwhelmingly
elected him with all of that on the
table so I understand a desire by seller
on the left and frankly some of the
media to want to comb through certain
documents that he has but the American
people are clearly satisfied with a guy
not only an election day but since he's
been elected his approval ratings gone
up like 20 some-odd points so not only
have they elected them they've become
more and more pleased with the job that
he's done and he hasn't even assumed the
office I thought you guys didn't like
polls but if we want to play with them
we know that more people are concerned
about his business dealings than those
who are not we know that his approval
rating is low compared to where other
president elects have been at this point
but let's at all live but let's dismiss
the polls you said they overwhelmingly
voted for him there is no definition of
overwhelming that would meet this vote
is one of the lowest it's one of the
lowest electoral margins we've had I
think it's 46 out of 50 something it's
one of the lowest in the last few cycles
we've had he won he's the president
elect he will present a United States
but I'm saying if you want to be
straight about it and transparent I
guess it wasn't overwhelming and no no
if you look at hold on hold on Chris
there is no
bunny on your network and the rest of
the media they gave him a chance going
into Election Day none how is that well
9 news weekend how does that make you an
overwhelming to say because to say that
he was gonna get crushed Hillary Clinton
was planning fireworks on the Hudson
where every think it was gonna happen he
wins with three hundred and six
electrodes nine of 13 battleground
states 2300 counties and you're saying
you doubt the weather that's
overwhelming yeah because it's about
100,000 it's about a hundred thousand
votes it's one of the smallest electoral
margins we've had and he lost the
popular vote by millions but he won I'm
not disputing that and I know you like
that as a distraction I'm not giving it
to you today what I'm saying of course
it is because you're assuming there's a
premise involved that is absent from
this discussion there is no suggestion
of D legitimizing the victory what I'm
saying is transparency which you were
touting yesterday is woefully lacking
where it matters most we do but not
what's know Kristin well the business
dealings are for the kids or for Trump
and you were supposed to tell us today
and you delayed it damn okay that was a
rare good job on CNN and credit to Chris
Cuomo for that back-and-forth there
because that's what he should be doing
all the time with all of his different
political guests who are either
representatives of politicians or they
are the politician so that is well done
because he wouldn't let him get away
he's trying to wiggle out wiggle out
with the ladies like no no no let me
explain this to you so first let's go to
the claim of overwhelming victory Chris
is right there's no definition of
overwhelming victory the Trump's win was
overwhelming even when you go to his
strongest claim which is the electoral
college when you do the comparison
between Trump's when in the electoral
college and the history of wins in the
electoral college there's only only John
Kerry and George Bush and George Bush
and Al Gore were closer in modern times
so most of them I mean there were
Electoral College wins of over 500
electoral vote
Bill Clinton one with I think be Bob
Dole with I think 361 obviously Obama
beat Romney and Obama beat McCain with
over one was 332 and I forget what the
other one was but it was well over 306
so this relates to a broader narrative
that we've been talking a lot about
that's actually backed up in a lot of
polling which is that many Trump
supporters are living in an alternate
reality many Trump supporters believe
that Donald Trump won the popular vote
for example many Trump supporters are
all of a sudden not concerned that a
foreign power according to numerous US
intelligence agencies including the FBI
and the CIA interfered in our election
specifically to help one particular
candidate the problem is this is working
and this has everything to do with
people like Sean Spicer which Kyle
talked about in that video and Anthony
SCARA Moochie who also faced off with
Chris Cuomo which is that the public the
the Trump is at large don't even realize
that they are being bamboozled because
they have this echo chamber and they've
been primed by Trump to be skeptical of
all news media now it's good to have
healthy skepticism of news in the sense
that you want to confirm you want to
independently look at a lot of different
claims that are made on a corporate
media an independent media fact check
everybody fact check me by all means but
the problem is that when you're already
predisposed to assume that the Trump
surrogate is right and corporate media
is hiding the truth you see Sean Spicer
talk about a historic win here or there
in that way or the other way and you
assume that it's true and you assume
corporate media is lying about easily
provable facts you look at any election
counter I think I mean maybe there are
some completely bogus popular vote
counters and you see that Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote by nearly
three million votes we have an echo
chamber now a self-fulfilling prophecy
where you have trumpets wanting to
believe everything they hear on
corporate media isn't true there are
many things that aren't true or that are
exaggerations or distortions but a lot
of the facts are still gotten correct on
corporate media and then you see a trump
surrogate denying that reality and now
you feel justified in your belief that
isn't at all backed by the facts this is
why even
though it is so hard to believe that
Trump is going to make America great
again for the average American
many trumpets no matter what he does
will come away believing that he did
make America great again and this is why
I know not everybody agrees with me on
this this is why convincing to 2016
trumpets to vote for somebody else in
2020 if Trump runs is not the past path
forward for progressives it's making
progressive turnout so high that it
doesn't matter if every Trump is votes
to re-elect him in 2020 I think that
this is a fundamental reality that
progressives need to accept